good evening tonight we celebrate the
beginning of a new academic year with
the opening of a comprehensive
exhibition of Stanley Tiger means half
century career as an architect and a
talk by mr. tiger minh the exhibition
secy napaa reverie not set as well as by
our professor 50 is a curated by
professor Emmanuel petit and it marks
the transfer of Tiger man's complete
drawing archive to Yale in 2012 we're
over 260 individual architecture
exhibition and design projects will be
available to students and scholars for
future study following its inaugural
presentation here at Yale the tiger main
exhibition will travel to the Graham
foundations Madeline our house galleries
in Chicago and then on to the University
of Illinois Champaign I wish to
acknowledge the support of the Graham
foundation and to welcome its director
Sara herder who is he here with us
tonight I believe although i haven't
seen her but Sarah where are you see you
maybe not or in the other room that
could be possible but she knew the rules
and there are men as well staff from the
foundation and very many friends of mr.
Tiger means of course we welcomed
enthusiastically to Yale I also wish to
thank it to acknowledge the support of
Elise Jaffe and jeffrey Brown and
helping making this making this
exhibition a reality and to thank former
exhibitions director dean Sakamoto for
his collaborative work with Emmanuel
petit in designing the show also not to
be overlooked our former is our former
exhibitions coordinated de niketan who
has relocated to Arizona but I also want
to thank gallery registrar Linda thought
ravisha and curatorial assistant of it
was mended snow with us I'm happy
say and and a curatorial assistant David
Reinhardt with m.ed 2011 for the great
good work David worked tirelessly and
imaginatively with Emmanuel in working
through the archives of Tiger main
office and putting together the amazing
compilation that you see in the
galleries as well I offer kudos to Karen
Carter Lynch of Chicago for the
excellent film conversation with Stanley
that was made for this exhibition and is
on view in the gallery and I urge you to
take a few minutes after the lecture
during the cocktail hour to stand in
front of the screen and see Stanley I'm
not on that beautifully put together
film it's my pleasure also to welcome
Brian Butterfield a recent graduate of
our school as joint was joined our
faculty as exhibitions director and to
draw your attention to a manual petites
work as editor of a collection of Slammy
tiger man's writings that has just been
published by the Yale press copies of
the book which is titled sleping through
ambivalence essays on an American
architectural condition will be on sale
in our gallery during the reception that
will follow tonight's lecture and
Stanley Tiger moon has graciously agreed
to sign copies after you've paid for
them
also on sale in the gallery at the same
time this evening arc will be copies of
designing bridges to burn architectural
memoirs of Stanley Tiger Minh which has
just been published by oral editions you
will sign those if you buy them Sammy
tiger man's lecture is the 28th Paul
Rudolph lecture the Rudolph lectures
were endowed by mr. and mrs. Moritz be
edish I'm to honor the architect of the
building in which some of us said summer
and Borya to the orator chimes and many
of us in this room tonight including our
speaker Paul Rudolph was a great
architect and a great friend the Edda
shines have been wonderfully kind to the
school in another way endow a
publication fund in Paul Rudolph's
memory from nineteen fifty eight to
nineteen sixty-five Paul Rudolph was
chairman of the department of
architecture in what we send the yale
school of art and architecture under his
leadership the school reached new
heights of influence as a center of
professional training & design inquiry
attracting brilliant students who went
on to brilliant careers one of the
brightest and most talented of these was
Stanley Tiger minh who though already a
certified professional architect with an
established career in Chicago offices
such as kak and CAC and skidmore owings
and merrill as a well as a fledgling
independent practice decided to come to
New Haven to study because of Paul
Rudolph I'm sure Stan we will tell you
more about that Rudolph in turn ranked
Stanley tiger men among his most
brilliant students and I can tell you
that not Stan this is not Stanley
bragging but I've heard it from Paul
Rudolph over and over again and close
professional and personal friends so to
have Stanley deliver the Rudolph lecture
tonight seems particularly fitting
I was a beginning student in the school
when Stanley was blazing his way through
what was then the master's class Tiger
Minh not only impressed Rudolph and
fellow and visiting critics like Philip
Johnson Gordon bunch F and James
sterling but almost all of the students
in the school who were in awe of his
talent his energy and his commitment to
excellence since that time stanley
hasn't changed i'm happy to say except
in one significant way adding to his
accomplishments as an architect he has
added a dimension of public
responsibility that is rare in our
profession stanley is not only a
distinguished architect but a man with a
mission from his perch in America's
second city Stanley enjoys an
international reputation as designer and
public scold using it I have to say that
about second set of you you knew that I
would say that yeah well what else is
there except Sammy enjoys an
international reputation as a designer
and a publix cold using his formidable
skill as a draftsman cartoonist and
writer to help keep the profession on
its best behavior and that's a full-time
job in and of itself in a profession
where leaders sell them have many nice
things to say about each other virtually
all who have known Stanley Tiger man and
his work agree he is a force majeure he
is a mensch please join me in welcoming
Sam wait aah Gurman as he delivers
tonight Paul Rudolph lecture
displacement Stanley
Thanks how can you hear me okay of
course I have a number of thank yous as
well before I begin but of course
primarily to Bob who has been a great
support and great and dear friend for
this half century I also want to thank
Michelle call me of Yale press who's
here without whom the book no thanks to
Peter Eisenman slapping through
ambivalence would not have occurred he
was against the title it's a little too
Jewish for Peter but
you get my drift um but my sincerest and
deepest thanks go to a manual petit
without whom none of this would have
transpired to have somebody with a
perceivable IQ behave as he's done in
expressing an idea of an other to use
Emmanuel Levinas his term as succinctly
as he's done his extraordinary and I owe
him a huge debt of things
I also want to this is actually highly
emotional I really also want to dedicate
this talk to dunker Ruffalo who died in
Chicago 25 days ago one day shy of his
53rd birthday which is to say the least
tragic okay in any case on with the show
I decided to do something tonight which
I've given a hell of a lot of thought to
that is normally not done by architects
that is to try and express what it is
that I've tried to do throughout my
career so I'm showing a number of images
that actually are directed at different
strategies about the word displacement
and I want to begin with the images on
the screen in the 12th century an
Andalusian polymath philosopher and
medical doctor named even to file wrote
the only document that's come down
through the centuries to us which is
called hi Evan yachts on which you see
here which is the image on your left
it's an incredible philosophic tale
about a feral autodidact who abandoned
by his mother almost in a mosaic kind of
story on a raft set adrift in the
Arabian Sea ends up on an island and is
raised by an animal by a deer a doe
years go by and the dough nurtures and
loves him in the way that only a mother
could do but at some point of course the
deer gets frail gets ill and then dies
stunned he tries to ascertain the source
of her love for him
and in the process not finding it he
dissects her or just the image on your
right and putting aside the organs all
that he finds left is the emptiness of
the cavity the thorax which is in each
of us which is about in a sense the
absence of presence and thus begins the
story of someone seeking what John
hajduk referred to as aura what in the
book to file refers to as a soul but is
really about ineffability the
unspeakable the unutterable which in
architecture is referred to often as the
poetic we tend not to talk about the
poetic and architecture because it's
something that can only be experienced a
drink can only engage in but you really
can't talk about so this is the
beginning of my search for the ineffable
and how I've gone about the business of
doing it in religion of course they
decide on the top is of the Kaaba in
Mecca which the queue around which
during a Haj circumnavigating in seven
times the faithful are at least one time
in their life are supposed to do the
image below of course is the empty tomb
of Jesus Christ so they're both spaces
and that question of the displacement of
what was once filled which once held the
body of Jesus Christ the emptiness of
the Kaaba and given the architectures
history from Hellenic Christian origins
on forward found their way in the 10th
century into the slide on the lower left
being a French cistercian monastery
above it is the monastery at cologne the
other two our wells in Durham the
cathedrals in England so there is an
incredible history of trying to find
that absence
the Axis Mundi that points toward heaven
and it's a part of our tradition and
it's had a huge impact on me as well as
the next slide will show which is the
cloister of the project identify an the
south i lurk you shoe in 1991 so it's
not only sacred space but it's also
profane space as well this was my entry
to a competition for an interfaith
multi-denominational space that was to
be in san francisco and its purpose of
being around in a way is all of the
twelve faiths depicted there or are
oriented correctly vasavi you enter the
via cistercian monastic president the
you enter the cathedral from the west
you enter the Jewish temple east east
southeast and similarly on the other
side of the circle of the Islamic one is
headed the same way so there was a
correctness implicit in the orientation
but that it attempted continuously seek
that which has been displaced and ending
up as space has been a part of my search
as well as the purpose of this talk is
actually since I see architecture if you
will as a communicable disease I'm
interested in conveying and i'm happy to
convey that which motivated me
throughout time this is the cloister of
the largest longest-running homeless
shelter in the united states the pacific
garden mission in chicago also oriented
correctly the plan which is above it on
the chapel is entered from the west is
oriented to the east is supposed to die
in the body of body and blood of Christ
and the square resident residual space
is marked by 12 trees represented the 12
tribes etc so all of that has
a huge impact on my life and to the
point i started making drawings this is
a sketch of another approach to the
search for ineffability if you will
which is what i will call lateral
displacement which you see on the
extreme left the torah which is that
incredible document that you actually
handle as you peel it aside to read the
text so it's been throughout history you
see at the end of the sikh on the way to
the treasury at petra the rock actually
exposing slowly what was in MO to that
at the time and then of course is its
over itself this incredible document
everything the earlier slides about
space is of christian hellenic origin
for the Jews it was a study of the book
of the people of the book so in other
words the text which in turn is encoded
because only the consonants are there so
it starts with the Torah this pulling
back to reveal ineffability and then in
1550 you find in Tivoli the villa d'este
ii by pure liguria which Nature has been
pulled back and watercourses down the
center of the villa a top of that slope
so that interest was always there and of
course then it with Thomas Jefferson it
she's got a long talk with the great
Jefferson scholar at the University of
Virginia about this Jefferson when he
designed the University of Virginia
before his influence by Benjamin latrobe
before is influenced by Pilate Oh after
going to Europe and aside from his
interest in books khwab books designed
the original plan of the university is
for parallel bars or something that was
in perpetuity open and you can read
about the
dramatic thing that that must have been
into for his book on utopia where to
free talks about this incredible
exercise in democracy that America
represented and the Jefferson tried to
capture in these four parallel bars
later after the influence of Latrobe
going to Europe of course he would add
these which for the did something
incredible and awful at some level
interpreting it it established hierarchy
the other was completely open now there
was hierarchy and then at the beginning
of the 20th century the entire center
section was closed off by McKim Mead and
white but the sidebars remain open in
Chicago in 1961 I am pay did this
incredible project called university
gardens in Hyde Park which on both sides
of fifty fifty two thousand foot long
imagine two thousand foot long parallel
bars slab blocks were design called
university gardens and their incredible
albeit that is now it is a lot of grown
landscaping but then he left it open
ended always I was stunned by personally
these are the things that influenced me
and of course Luke on oriented correctly
east west by the way as was university
gardens and the openness to the Pacific
Ocean the Setting Sun and to see those
true albeit crenellated parallel bars of
the Salk Institute and that having the
center filled with water so you couldn't
even inhabit the center if you remember
the incredible movie made by one of his
children Nathaniel and there's a scene
in a movie or he's rollerblading over
that center body of water I'm he's an
incredible moving experience and an
incredible act of restraint bike on to
not fill in the end of those parallel
bars so when we finished early this year
two villas in Michigan that mark McCurry
primarily and me secondarily did was the
same thing only in this case it's not
only an absence center that because
their self similar they're not identical
because they're 44 therefore fraternal
siblings but each of those villas is in
turn cleaved and has an open center
which is only there for vertical
circulation or passing left and right to
go to destination spaces so these things
have had a huge impact on me another one
which is in the show that Emmanuel put
in up in the gallery is a funerary
monument for a client of mine who was
Jewish was married to a Gentile woman
and the idea was to have each of their
families on either side of this sheared
cleaved object in Rose Hill Cemetery in
Chicago oriented correctly so the Jews
are headed east anticipation of
Messianic age the Gentiles oriented west
via the cistercian monastic precedent
now in Judaism of course when you do
it's not just a simple cleaving back and
forth you open up a space which when i
designed this unbuilt project for a
reform congregation in mettawa just west
of lake forest the Chicago suburbs of
their synagogue there was we found an
existing log Lodge oriented 6 degrees
east of south of east in other words
toward the west wall in jerusalem and i
surrounded by it by a fragment of
Solomon's Temple oriented due east so
that the differential between the two
orientations that bracket the coming of
Jesus in other words the East in terms
of anticipation of Messianic age and
like them
the muslims oriented as opposed
structural is phenomena for the Jews
back to the west wall of Jerusalem so
that led ultimately decades later to my
being commissioned to do the Holocaust
Museum of Illinois in skokie and there
was an interview process with a number
of architects who as often as the case
came to their various interviews with
PowerPoint presentations consultants god
knows what I actually threw away the
letter inviting me I either get up on
the wrong side of the bed that morning
or whatever Margaret my good
Episcopalian wife with her entire
rooming group from her senior year
advisor his Navy wives club are all here
tonight okay she insisted that I go so I
went to the interview after I was on a
plane doing something giving a lecture
and i made this sketch show the sketch
an hour a half later i was commissioned
and I then built it per the sketch
what's interesting about that the sketch
that led to this is that space of
ineffability that was opened up due to
the two orientations which is only
inhabited by an authentic 1934 German
boxcar in other words it's not for human
beings it's for the deceased which is
what it's about so it becomes in a way a
space that only can be understood after
death the next section I want to talk
about emanuel talks about it in the
exhibition as well is scaffolding now
the scaffold is an interesting phenomena
that up until recently primarily not
entirely but primarily is a sign
semiotic ly speaking of a building going
up or a building coming down with this
massive recession it's taken on a new
meaning this is of a project by Jove
valerian Chicago that's been shuttered
for
nearly five years there's another one in
Chicago on the river that's about 23
stories in the air that's also been
shuttered in other words the scaffold
has another meaning now of the
ambivalent condition representing what
going up coming down or hovering in
between but the scaffold hazoori as
precedent Edison's in art and
architecture interestingly all in the
same year in 1923 and for 13 or 14 years
after Frank Lloyd Wright had his seminal
show of it led to the publication called
the fahza myth portfolio in Berlin that
was seen by all of the European
architects of the day predominantly Mies
van der Rohe but this painting by
Mondrian is another example in a way of
scaffolding and these two images that
you know very well the one your left the
building a new trek by gerrit rietveld
the one of the Schrader house the one on
your right an axonometric done by theo
van doesburg also in 1924 had a huge
impact on me such that when in the late
80s I was commissioned by Heinrich clots
then the director that gorgeous
architecture museum as he commissioned a
number of other architects to do an
installation about man's original home
and Margaret and I were in Europe in the
middle of a lecture tour and I went to
look at all as I'd the first choice I
picked the niche that it was effectively
unbuildable because it had two trees in
it and there was only one thing to do
was to measure the trees orienting the
scaffold toward Jerusalem and as it was
cut short to allow for the trees growth
um it was about the subject of
measurement which Emanuel talked about
earlier which you'll see in that book
that Michelle so kindly published is
also a great interest of mine so the
scaffold the grid the matrix has been
huge in my life to the point when I did
the Formica showroom at the merchandise
mart we did an incredible matrix
oriented normal to the building and then
shifted six degrees south of east toward
Jerusalem once again with when it was
cut allowing you to walk through where
all of the samples of Formica so using
every opportunity I could I tried to
engage that as i did in fukuoka in 1990
and the focal ganesha jaye shoma mochi
housing project the one on the left is
by michael graves now one of the right i
did and you'll see a 2 by 2 meter grid
on the outside that deteriorates as
sudden as the building does do not cast
its shadow on its neighbor but it's an
item of measurement I mean the one thing
that there is a certain innocence maybe
not so much for Saul Bellow but for me
about the scaffold about measuring
itself the concept of measurement not to
steal your thunder because I know next
week you're giving a lecture on
scaffolding but scaffolding or the grid
has been as looms very large in my life
as well to the point that this project
in madrid when Martha thorn now back in
Spain but in between coming to Chicago
when she was originally an expat in
Madrid she was head of the cultural
commission of Madrid at a time when
Madrid was a cultural capital of Europe
and she asked five different architects
from five parts of the world to do an
urban intervention and when I went to
Madrid to check out the site
suchita the sign none appealed to me
until driving by the Al Madina which is
the major Cathedral in Madrid I
discovered to my horror that the
cathedral was Miss oriented it's
oriented not to the west where you can
enter its oriented to the north next to
the Royal Palace where there's a great
statue of Philip the second so that the
monarchy transcended theology and it
really annoyed me no end and I decided
to do a corrective so with scaffoldings
and so much of Europe is under scaffold
I reoriented and finally this project
which was in Chicago at the spertus
College of Judea candy bracket I think
BB who was one was here tonight was one
of them that was asked a number of us
were asked to design a Sukkot that
temporal booth during the Jewish holiday
sukas and a fallen Catholic in my employ
Susan O'Brien and a non-observant Jew
designed it working strictly from the
book of seasons the text so this follows
textually all that and again it's a
gridded scaffold I'm done in transitory
materials temporal materials bamboo so
that that strategy of trying to come to
grips with poetry as it were has been a
huge part of my life now the last
section I want to talk about begins with
obviously a pre modernist condition
pillados villa rotunda the building's
started by Claudio unfinished bicycle
Nazi in vicenza where the building is
bilaterally symmetrical
buildings in a pre-modern stage were not
just bilaterally symmetrical the coining
of their corners with dread stone
anchored them firmly into that tradition
which was a representation or a
representation of the rooms beyond that
changed dramatically in 1910 with Frank
Lloyd Wright's Fossum a--the exhibition
in Berlin and then the portfolio has
exemplified here by the Robie house in
Chicago in other words he broke out of
the box how do you break out of a box
you do it at the corner your break out
like so if you can see out of the corner
that had such an impact on the
architects of the day I can't begin to
tell you but I know no greater influence
was Felton by mies van der rohe who not
many years later in 1928 was
commissioned on very short notice to
design the German pavilion and the
exhibition World's Fair of Barcelona and
Meis understood entirely was moved
entirely in his own words by Frank Lloyd
Wright not just in plan but in elevation
in section so the roof is revealed as
well Frank Lloyd Wright not to be
outdone in 1934 is commissioned by Edgar
Kaufmann to design this house falling
water in bare Ron Pennsylvania 1934 is
three years after Philip Johnson and
Henry Russell Hitchcock co-authored the
exhibition and catalog of international
architecture the International style
right did not play a major part in that
exhibition as did Schindler play no part
was excluded entirely largely because of
their expressive qualities in the lack
of the reductive modernist conditions
that really were to Johnson exemplary of
modernism so here in 1923 and for his
niece's house for a bachelor and brick
and if you notice the plan and then the
way that he's taken the right Ian
condition of that 1910 exhibition and
what he's done with it is extraordinary
that had a huge impact on two
generations of architects for sure one
of which was me so that in nineteen 59
and 60 in my bachelor's thesis two
things become evident a plan which is
anything but symmetrical alluding back
to me sin many ways but also an
elevation which is a symmetrel in a
pinwheel forum which was very crucial to
exemplify that condition leaping far
forward to today Margaret and I were
commissioned by the University of
Chicago to move the seminary co-op
bookstore to a place one block east of
the theological seminary we're moving
our out into a building immediately
adjacent to the Robie house which if I
can get this thing to work is somewhere
the Robie house somewhere to the right
so it's my opportunity to come to grips
with Frank Lloyd Wright once again and
inside the bookstore are six figural
voids three simple three more complex
but each of the six entered
asymmetrically there was the denial of
centeredness now all of this is in the
context of our Hellenic Christian
tradition of seeking ideality seeking
the hadouken aura or as Carla Britain is
put it succinctly
enough ability but that's the Western
pantheon of values there's another one
which is in part exemplified by the loge
a primitive Hut written by Joseph River
in 1971 the entire book with a very
small second with with the exception of
a very small section is about
architecture in the West with a small a
the small section in the book that's
interesting which is what I want to end
with in a way is he talks to the
Japanese tea ceremony and there is a
tradition outside of his Western
pantheon of beauty that's only
understood in a Buddhist Eastern culture
which is called wabi-sabi which is shown
here in an image I want to leave with
you as the road not taken now wabi-sabi
is about something that we continues to
deny which is death for wabi-sabi in the
east the condition that nothing is
finished nothing less and nothing is
perfect is actually understood and
appreciated we're only death is what is
perfect so I want to leave you with that
image but in conclusion on a lighter
note i want to call baba because I have
something for him which is this last
image which is not about me it's more
about what's written by Bob Stern which
says o captain my captain our fearful
trip is done and so it is not quite hell
thanks
you
you take some questions Thank You
Stanley for a beautiful talk and a
modest talk surprised life is full of
surprises now he has agreed to take
questions if there are any and I hope
there will be some and we have someone
with microphones people with microphones
on each side so is there a question for
Stanley Maggie Deemer down front please
we need the mic because people will want
to hear the question and the answer in
the other rooms thank you and I was
impressed when you talked in the gallery
about your commitment or to symmetry and
that in some way you simply could not
not do it and you showed projects here
where you're breaking out but even there
it's around a center when you're with
them the spiral and so so then once that
becomes clear I'm curious about the
transition from a symmetry that is
resolved and appreciated in the
classical sense and one then that as you
were saying gets fractured and divided
and is about the cleavage we're really
becomes about opposition we're really
what you're showing off is that these
two things one can't come together and
to that the center is voided so to me
that's a not just a formal
transformation but as you're indicating
here is a kind of spiritual
transformation so I'm curious to know
about that moment where the classical
symmetry simply could not be maintained
anymore and you really were going to me
what looks like its opposite even though
it's formal you know mirror mirror
possibilities are still there well
actually begi I think each of us how do
I say this cogently because I've never
believed in one overarching way to make
anything
when I tried to talk about tonight are
the number of things the four or five
differentiated forces that have acted
out in my life the scaffold the voided
center etc and the asymmetry that right
was the first to discover in 1910 say so
that it's not just one thing that's had
an impact on influencing the way I
design buildings I tried to explain in
his brief quite about modest talk the
several things that have had an impact
on me as a manual put it very nicely
both in the catalog and the
introductions of the two books that I've
written and in his verbal description of
the exhibition curated I've never
believed in one overarching correct way
of doing anything now having come from
Chicago and a product of a Mies hegemony
it really had a huge impact perhaps
negatively on my life as well I never
saw because I'm not one for whom faith
is uber alles I've always tried to
interpret I'm more interested in xing
exegetical about analysis and so that's
what this talk tonight I'm just trying
to express the different things that
have had an impact on me but one in
terms of symmetry because I could never
quite come to grips with it spatially my
way was to cleave it there are lots of
slides I could have shown for sure that
a manual has ended exhibition like the
Berlin villa of breaking it into two one
of which Bob did one of which hey Doc
did etc in my case using the pearls
house of 1909 by mies van der rohe
I cut it into as I said during the
gallery walk I'm never Jewish and you
work in Berlin you're not about to let
it alone so I want him cut it into it
was a violent act it was done very
consciously for sure so I mean as I said
also on walking through the gallery one
of the reasons i have a small if almost
not discernible practice is because I've
never said the right thing too many of
you like Patrick Vanel and sat on juries
with me to know that that's true so I
don't know that it's an answer Peggy
that's the best I can give you was it
not just it's either this or that
there's not an overarching but whether
there's a narrative that as a linear
narrative about that transformation in
or out or through but but but I think
you're explaining it is some well
actually you know breaking it up into
the various components that Emanuel did
it's a manuals exhibition I on the great
deal and as I've told him before I saw
the show today there's no way I can live
up to that I mean did an extraordinary
job in curating designing and executing
the exhibition the catalog and the two
introductions and making sense out of
you and making sense to the degree it's
possible no manual is the one that we
all I certainly owe a huge debt to I
think you do too because it's a terrific
show and it's not about me it's about a
manual it's tough
he may have sunk your career right now
that's the story of my life I'm trying
to help his career I say and in the
process I say him is there another
question yes Eduardo yeah thanks I had a
question about the your use of color and
I was really struck by how when you were
talking about the Creed and the
scaffolding and you took us back to the
projects of wytheville and thunders work
and they use they did off the color
somehow also got into the way you use
color in those scaffolding projects and
I was thinking I wanted to ask you
whether the way you use color with the
scaffoldings is different in the way you
use color in other projects well you
know again I've used color in a variety
of ways it's not just one overarching
way so for example the paintings that
are on the wall of the gallery that I
didn't have mid 60's in Chicago we're
entitled as a manual referred to in the
exhibition walkthrough I pledge
allegiance to the lozenge and to the
implications for which it stands how is
it's a play on the Pledge of Allegiance
in the United States so it's at once
cynical but it's also red white and blue
surprise I've also used caller in quite
another way like in the library for the
blind there are basically according to
library of congress definition of
blindness there's really only about
blindness is for people whose have sight
of visual problems of twenty percent or
more so they can vaguely see color so
when I did the library for the blind I
used primary colors that would resonate
with the blind user that was very
important to me I've also used color on
other occasions representing earth water
fire it's
so you know I know that this is not
within the traditional condition of
architectural presentations where
there's one overarching way to do
something I'm a kind of chameleon or dr.
Dolittle in a way of architecture I can
you know because I never had one
overarching correct way that I believed
in coming from a town that was one
overarching way and responding to it
I've been embattled by it has given me
the freedom to do a lot of things I know
it may not be an answer that you like or
you want but I can only say it's the
truth enough other questions no yes
sorry hi Stanley what the image before
the last image which was the in the the
image which with all of the green the
seasonally changing image you're talking
about transitional adjustment
ephemerality the I'm trying to figure
out what you're talking about because
the one of the last times I saw you
speak you ended your talk by thinking
about some criticism that you received
for your work some suggest critique in
the press essentially and you
essentially ended the top by saying to
paraphrase you that the best revenge
against the critics is to create
permanence in your buildings you know
buildings that just never go away and
change so can you just talk a little bit
more about that yeah I think it comes
you know my I'm 10 years older than Bob
but he's also getting on I feel and I
think when you age when you near your
endgame when you near death how you
begin to understand about what this
Buddhist philosophy of nothing is
finished nothing less nothing is perfect
which is very different than the Western
pantheon
beauty to which we've all aspired to the
end one with God at some level to be to
seek the ineffable the unspeakable in a
certain way so that last that next to
last image before this thing of Bob's is
about that which you begin to appreciate
as you near death which is the
imperfection in life I mean we all have
clients me too who continuously seek
perfection continuously change their
travertine floor make everything clean
perfect but nothing is that way
everything deteriorates but it's not in
our culture to appreciate that in this
Western pantheon of values so it's
really as i said in brief the road not
taken but that doesn't mean that I don't
appreciate it or that I don't understand
it so wabi-sabi I would address
everybody to look it up it's quite
interesting that and very different from
our sense of values of ID allottee yeah
Tom baby has a question this is going to
be good
Stanley actually in all years that we
did show some things together I mean I
think the most amazing thing to me was
your sense of humor and actually the
humor ran into the architecture if you
could just talk briefly because i think
it's sort of a central theme in a way
that runs to your life how does humor I
mean the only architect I know we
actually seriously took you more
seriously in buildings and i think it's
a it's a very kind of powerful aspect of
your work and I if you talk about it I'd
appreciate it well as a manual said in
the catalog he also accused you of using
humor I mean humor for my from my
perspective is about approach avoidance
it's about the approach avoidance of
death that there is some ironic
component I mean I'm waiting for Yale
price to publish his doctoral thesis
from Princeton and Manuel petites which
is on ironing I mean it is a major
subject now irony is problematic because
it flies in the face of John headaches
reducing distance between subject and
object and it by giving yourself
distance that making commentary about
others and other things you achieve some
distance but there is something humorous
ironic in the face of death that we all
in various ways throughout our career do
it there's no question about it so I can
look at drawings that bob has made over
the years that are also ironic that are
not so straight-laced it's just that I'm
in my case well for example the Daisy
house which is something among other
projects that Bob Stern has always said
how are you going to live this down
but it was done for a guy as a manual
points out who came to me dying he came
to me with a double colostomy he had
intestinal cancer and I really didn't
want to do the project I didn't
important I didn't all go to it yeah he
ran strip joints in cal city it's my
kind of claim it's what I get sort of
architecture with a small egg and I
decided to make him laugh so thus the
Daisy oz he laughed he loved the house
lived in it for three months and died so
is that ironic is it fair to engage
humor in that way I mean these are
open-ended questions so Tom I don't know
it's hard for me to answer it as
succinctly as I'd like but humorous is
something I've taken as you know very
seriously it isn't just it isn't just
doing fun things it isn't just as Bob
and I or reminiscing with Peter Eisenman
early earlier about the 1976 venice
biennale that Peter put both of us and
others in it isn't just a Levin I can
Herman Hertzberg being thoroughly
annoyed by my dirty postcards which was
off the wall anyway because it was an
ironic commentary about American
architecture there is something serious
about irony and there is something
serious about humor humor is not just
joking us and there's a side of us that
I've tried to capture in my work for
better and worse in whatever a limited
talent I can focus on that to express
the ironic condition whereby we're here
for this amount of time there's a recent
poem you'll read in The New Yorker of
this African American poet that talks
about that we're here for just hours
maybe a day and then we're gone it's not
something that one talks about all the
time so how do you approach the finite
condition of temporality other than
through irony and all
that so it's one of the reasons I for
one was thoroughly appreciative of what
a manual did his take on me at some
level because nobody has actually ever
done that before and I really
appreciated that that irony and humor
are not just fun subjects Tom I wrote
that really I mean it's been such a
large part of my life that I don't know
how else to answer it have any other
questions yes when we bring the might
write down the front hello amen of you
experience I'm just wondering what can I
advice you will give young students in
these days what kind of 1 by 5 students
and also drivers to the younger students
and also what's the secret of your
success both last partner what is the
secret of your success people think
you're a success family that's cuz you
have a manual let me correct that
misapprehension I don't see myself as a
success when you read the autobiography
and why I became an architect and what I
grew up with in a very poor household in
Chicago and a mother who equated success
with money I've done everything in my
power through approach avoidance to not
be a success at some love life succeeded
so I suppose I am successful my advice
to students you know sort of like when I
said with Peter and his students earlier
today and Peter and I were talking
informally about certain things in our
past and when I said to his students was
that they need to get close to him and
not have distance they need to break
down the barriers it's with John
headaches
to reduce the distance between subject
and object and when you do that you can
begin to understand irony by the way
before I forget the one thank you I
didn't make was for these flowers which
is from Frank Gehry I told you up from
tramways the only architect other
architects like so thank you all thank
you all very much